- I don't need to express myself
or go on a Twitter rant and
tell people what I need,
or “I should win Rookie of the Year
because I did this, I did that.”
- You're doing it again.
- I’m answering your question.
- No, no, no. You're deflecting.
- I believe that I can be the best
running back to ever play the game.
- OK, leaving one hotel
to head to the airport cuz
we're going to L.A.
to interview New York Giants
running back Saquon Barkley.
Why are we going to L.A.
to interview a New York Giant?
He's training there.
Why are we going to L.A.
to interview a New York Giant?
He's training there.
Saquon had an amazing rookie season.
He was Rookie of the Year.
Even though he is one of the
best running backs in the league,
he still hasn't said it.
I have arrived, about to interview Saquon.
The crew is setting up.
Were you reading those?!
- Where’d you get these chairs?
- We matched the piano.
- Oh yeah, that makes sense.
- So we still saying “Gucci”?
You Gucci, you ready?
- What's the story behind your name?
- There's really no crazy message behind it.
My full name is Saquon Rasul Quevis Barkley.
- Say that again, slowly.
- Saquon Rasul Quevis Barkley.
Rasul means “one sent,” and Quevis is a name
that my mom and my aunt kinda came up
with when they thought of a cute boy name.
- So when you’re to get in trouble,
is your mama sayin’, “Saquon Rasul Quevis,”
is she saying all of them together?
- Nah, nah, nah.
- Were there any other names
under consideration besides Saquon?
- Yeah, um, Tupac.
- You could’ve been Tupac Barkley?
- Yeah, Tupac Makaveli.
My dad's a big Tupac fan.
I think the year before, Tupac died,
and he was trying to name me Tupac Makaveli.
And my mom was not having that at all.
- But how close were we
to having to Tupac Barkley, like—
- Real close. Real close, real close.
Till my mom put her foot down.
- How did you know Jada
was the right name for your one-year-old daughter?
- We didn't find out the gender till birth,
which I think was pretty cool.
So when she came out, we knew the name.
We kinda set on, Amari was gonna be a boy,
and Jada was gonna be a girl
When she pushed out that baby, we said, “Jada.”
- What scares you about fatherhood?
- I don't think really anything scares me.
Your mistakes is now obviously in the spotlight,
that reflects on your daughter, and
your daughter's gonna know.
And you know, you also gotta be man enough
to be honest about those mistakes.
Like how my parents and my family was.
- What mistake that your parents made
have you learned the most from?
- Mmm, you know, business mistakes.
My father had a little, you know, drug history
in the past that my mom helped him get through.
Stuff like that really helped me
to become the person I am today.
- What kind of person are you?
- Great question.
Type of person I wanna be—
- No, what kind of person are you?
- Oh, right now?
- Right now.
- Um, I would say a hard worker.
A dad.
Um...put me on the spot there.
Lemme think a little more.
- Do you realize that when you talk about yourself,
you get so much more subdued
than when you talk about anything else?
- I didn't notice that.
- When you were at the Pro Bowl,
ESPN asked you to make your case
for Rookie of the Year.
- Mhmm.
- And I just want to show you your answer, OK?
- Nothing taken away from, from Baker.
He had a tremendous year.
What he did for the Browns was unbelievable,
so definitely much respect to him.
But I think, you know, I'm—
I don’t know how to answer that question.
- Um, I think, you know, if you watch film and
you watch my peers and you see people that play
against me and coaches that play against me,
they can answer that question better than I can.
I didn't really answer that question, really.
- It took you about 35 seconds to talk about you.
- I don't need to express myself or go on a Twitter rant
or go on a rant on ESPN and tell people what I need,
or “I should win Rookie of the Year
because I did this, I did that.”
No, I don’t, I don’t need to do that. And if I did,
that wasn’t gonna help me win or lose anyway.
But that's what everyone expects me to do.
- Running back Jonathan Stewart said that you
can be the greatest running back of all time.
Is Jonathan Stewart right?
- Um, you know, got a lot of respect
for Jonathan Stewart.
- No, no, no. You're doing it again.
- I’m answering the question.
- No, no, no. You are deflecting.
- OK. All right. I’ll open up. All right.
- Is he right?
- Yes. I believe so.
Um, I believe that I can be the best
running back to ever play the game.
That good?
- Was that hard?
- No.
- Look! We dappin’? Are we dappin’ or—
- There you go. Let’s get a better one.
- I am so proud of you.
You won't say that you are the greatest
at anything except for Connect Four.
- Mhmm.
- You claim to be the GOAT—
- Yes.
- Of Connect Four.
- I’m the GOAT at Connect Four.
I mean, I haven’t played in a minute, but I am—
Obviously, Michael Jordan took some Ls
before in life, so I take Ls,
but I get majority.
Only one person’s up on me right now.
- Who's up on you?
- I don't really wanna say—
- Nope.
- Christian McCaffrey.
I got cocky and, like, I just made a
wrong move, and he got me.
And, like, it still bothers me,
especially cuz it’s Christian.
And, like, obviously that’s my boy,
but you’re a running back and, like,
we compete against each other.
So he's up on me right now.
So, Christian, if you see this, I need my rematch.
- We'll see today cuz you said
you wanted a big Connect Four.
We brought one, and we’re gonna play.
- Loser got pushups.
- Sure.
- All right, there we go.
- I don't know why I just agreed to that.
- Y’all saw that, so that means it’s happening.
- I’ll start first?
- Uhhh, no. I go first.
- Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
- No, I go first.
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
Boom.
Ahhh, I hate when it comes down to this one!
OK.
- I already know what you’re gonna throw.
- No you don't.
- Mhmm.
- OK.
Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
Boom.
- Damn, OK.
- I thought you knew what I was gonna throw?
I knew what you were gonna throw.
- It’s whatever.
- OK.
Your high school athletic director, Bob Hartman,
once described you as “a kid who is a pleaser.
He doesn't want to make people angry.”
How much do you agree
with that assessment of yourself?
- Uh, a lot.
- Any time someone is talking about you,
whether it's your friends, your family, your teammates,
they all use one word to describe you: nice.
Are you too nice?
- Sometimes. Sometimes I’m too nice, yes.
But I've been working on that because in this industry,
you have to learn how to say no.
And it's not just always about pleasing other people.
Sometimes you gotta do what's best for you.
- Why do you put other people before
maybe what you want to do?
- I just feel like in my heart, that’s the right thing to do.
- In what ways have you seen yourself
try to be more selfish?
- You go from having nothing, and then in 10 seconds
having money, I guess you could say.
People come out the woodworks.
You know, everyone wanna be a part of you.
Keeping your circle tight and worry about taking care
of them and not taking care of everybody else.
You could say that's when I
became a little bit more selfish.
Oooh. Oh no, don’t do that. Don’t put that in.
- Look who fumbled! Saquon Barkley.
- That was good. That was a good switchup.
I like that, ain’t gonna lie. But no.
All right, let’s go.
- OK.
- I'm making a wrong move, I think.
- If you’d have went here, you’d have had me both ways.
That’s how I know you don’t play this game.
- I’m not good at this game.
What do you think, Jada? Should I go here?
Yeah? She says yes. So if I lose, it’s cuz of Jada.
- Game.
- Where? No!
Is it difficult for you to hear a lot of the criticism
that Eli Manning gets as a quarterback?
- Yeah, it bothers me, I’m not gonna lie,
because it's, it's not his fault.
He’s not the reason why we went 5-11.
We lost seven or eight games this year
by seven points or less as a team.
We love to put the blame on one person.
But in football, it takes 11 men.
I'm fine with having only 1,200 yards next year,
1,300 yards next year, but with a 12-4 record.
- How crazy is it that there are people out there
who watched you play your rookie year
but still think the
Giants should have drafted a quarterback?
- That's mind-boggling to me.
- But tell me why it's mind-boggling to you.
- Because, like, I think that what I was able to show
not only on the field, but off the field, that they’d
think they made the right decision
- Because, like, I think that what I was able to show
not only on the field, but off the field, that they’d
think they made the right decision
- In what ways are you and Baker Mayfield similar?
- Work ethic, I would say.
If we’re both able to stay healthy
and do what we can do, that we might see each
other in the Super Bowl one day.
- In what ways are you and Baker Mayfield different?
- Um...what way I would say
that we’re different, um. Hmm.
She’s good.
I’ll tell you that. She’s good.
Let me take another little second to think.
Different, let me think.
He's white, I’m black. I’m joking.
Um, I would say a difference in coming out of college.
He had to prove something and had to show what
everyone was saying was right in that,
“I'm even better than what everyone was saying.”
I would say that was a difference
that we had to do in our draft process.
- So he was trying to prove people wrong.
- Mhmm.
- You were trying to prove people right.
- Yeah, but also wrong cuz I'm
better than what they said.
Ah, nah. I'm not. I am. But, OK, whatever.
- But look at this! Look at you.
- Do not put that on there.
- No, that was good.
- Don’t put that on there.
That's what you need,
to be able to say that.
- Do not put that on there.
- All right, you and Baker Mayfield recently went
on a vacation to Turks and Caicos.
- Mhmm.
- Who’s more fun on vacation?
- Um, I would say him. I'll admit, I'll say he's probably
more fun cuz I had to come over, like, a fear.
I do not mess with open water at all.
Like, I don't necessarily like sharks
and fishes and stuff like that.
- So wait, when you're looking
in the water about to jump,
what’s going through your head?
- Just saying,
“Please don’t let a shark be down there.
Like, please do not let anything—”
Like, sharks is not the only scary thing in there.
I don’t even mess with dolphins.
Like, I don’t mess with nothing in there.
Like, I can’t be the only one sitting out on the yacht,
and Shep, Bake and Lil’ D are all in there,
and I’m just sitting there like,
“Ah, nah, I’m not doin’ that.”
So I had to conquer my fear,
and I was able to do it.
But I would definitely say Baker is definitely more fun
to vacation than me, but I'm getting better at it, yeah.
- Yeah.
Would you say that's your biggest fear though,
like, open water?
- Um, open water? Nah, my biggest fear,
I’m being honest, ticks.
Mmm, I don’t mess with ticks, like, whatsoever.
- Ticks, like the insect?
- Like the insect. Like, they’re disgusting.
- [Laughing] That’s a very specific thing
to be scared of.
Have you ever been bitten by a tick?
- Yes, I did. I saw it, and I freaked out.
I, like, stripped butt-naked and I was like,
“Mom, Mom, Mom!”
My mom had to, like, get it out
- Yeah.
- I’d still flip out now actually.
- To open water and ticks.
- Mhmm.
- Make sure your opponents know,
open water and ticks.
- Exactly, exactly.
- That's how to get to you.
- Oooh, she whistled!
I’m just curious, like, is this how you see like—
you know what I mean, like, the gaps or anything?
- I would say no.
It's not like chess, but it’s a game that
you have to think steps ahead.
- Yeah.
Like when you're playing football,
you're playing a game,
you have to think steps ahead.
How you’re gonna set up the defense,
how you’re gonna set up the defender.
- Yeah.
Obviously it’s nowhere near the level
of what it actually is, but kind of similar thinking.
- So whenever we have a guest,
we have them answer a series of questions.
I want you to take me to a certain time,
place, experience. OK?
- OK.
- Take me to your leg workout.
- Mmm, which one? Squats?
- Tell me, tell me the routine.
- Routine, you know, quads.
Obviously quads. Hamstrings—
- How much pride do you take in your quads?
- It was never a thing at all.
Like, everyone said I had big legs,
but it was never, like, a thing,
and people weren’t obsessed with it
till I got to the NFL.
Now, like, if I wear short shorts—like, I’ll walk
in an airport, and old ladies would come up to me
and be like,“Oooh, you got nice legs.”
Before that, it was never like,
“Oooh, you have nice legs.”
I always just had legs.
- Take me to your go-to karaoke song.
- It's Mario, “Let Me Love You.”
- How do you sing the song?
- Tryin’ to get me.
[Singing] Baby, I just don't get it.
I ain’t gonna give you too much.
- Oh, come on! You have to
at least do one line.
- Listen, listen, cuz my singing, my rapping career
is gonna come on a little bit later so I can’t—
- Oh, so you gotta wait.
- Gotta keep ‘em tuned in, you know?
You feel me? Just a little bit.
I kinda got you, lowkey. I ain’t gonna lie.
- I know, I don't—like, it doesn't matter
what I do, you're gonna win.
- Yeah, just lettin’ you know.
- Well, you know, you know
Christian McCaffrey’s still up, so it's cool.
Christian McCaffrey’s still the better
Connect Four player.
- That's crazy you brought that back up, not gonna lie.
That’s a smart move.
- I thought maybe if I distracted you—
- Yeah, yeah, I like that.
- Ah, you saw what I was doing.
Good for you.
You're the better Connect Four player.
Yay.
- Pushups.
- Thanks for doin’ the interview.
- No, pushups.
- No.
- Did you not agree to that?
- I'll do one.
- Five.
I don't even know if I can do one.
- Down. I’ll count that.
Two. I count that.
Three. Four. Five.
- There you go.
- I need to work on my form.
Saquon.
- What’s good?
So it has been, like, a couple weeks since
I interviewed you in L.A., and two days
after our interview, Odell got traded.
- It's sad to see him go.
Every time people come ask me,
“How you feel about Odell?”
Like, obviously, that's my boy. I'm upset.
Like, I don't think anyone's gonna sit out here
and say, “Oh, we're happy Odell got traded,”
but at the same thing, it’s a business.
And, you know, we gotta continue to work.
- OK, so have you seen Odell since?
- We hung out. It didn’t feel real.
It was like, dang. He walked in, like, with a Cleveland
shirt cuz he was just done working out.
And I was like, “Dang,
you over here in a Cleveland shirt already.”
You never know.
One day hopefully we can compete
in a Super Bowl one day.
- So if Odell’s not on the team anymore,
I mean, what happens to the dancing?
- Oh, we gonna try to get Eli along
with some dance moves soon.
- All right, now lastly, I have to ask.
Now Baker and Odell are on a team together.
Do you feel a little left out?
- No, no. You know,
I do not feel left out at all.
I'm happy for those guys.
- All right, we're going to wrap
this video up with a selfie.
- We have Rookie of the Year right here,
who was just fantastic in this interview.
How’d it feel?
- Thank you so much, it was amazing.